et maintenant plus des relations mon lev
et les relations je connais la baronne
du mail son fils à maman bénévole chez
eux une fois par semaine dont le voici
la baronne marianne brandstetter
monsieur
bonsoir bonsoir qui arrive je forme mes
laurent
laurent non ça c'est bon enfant elles
nous invitent les rentrées dans le sac
franchement vous avez demandé un parasol
pas trop pas de la plage bien donc un
hung rambert une des plus grandes
actrices françaises larusso une
chanteuse exceptionnelle
laurent baffie mon ami et lorànt deutsch
l'artiste qui m'ont oui vous ferez bien
vous avez une algue sur la tête ses bras
c'est chez clim ariane votre chapeau
emmaüs qui fait sa job c'est galliano
c'est magnifique lac et le sac d'oignon
marianne 27 heures vous publiez avec
henry jean servat
chez flammarion un livre intitulé la
baronne alors laurent baffie va vous
montrer comment on fait marianne
attention où l'on montre à la marianne
témoin non
un livre étonnant qui du nazisme aux
bahamas raconte votre parcours
une vie pleine de rebondissements
jusqu'à la jet set que vous incarnez
d'une certaine façon aujourd'hui on peut
le dire il n'y a pas que la classe et
rijkaard plein de trucs c'est un melting
potes la saisissante un livre que vous
avez écrit sur un paquebot de luxe en 21
jours pendant la traversée jusqu'aux
bahamas avec henry jean servat
parce que depuis le 11 septembre vous ne
prenez plus l'avion marianne non j'avais
pas alors j'ai pris le bateau faut avoir
un peu de temps mais c'est tellement
plus agréable et on rencontre deux amis
ont fait des connaissances et on peut
faire du sport sur le bateau non mais
c'est que c'est pas facile auront la vie
de jet s'agira julien déjà médecin je
sais que marianne partage son temps
entre miami monaco et new york entre le
shopping et le sport c'est un peu votre
vie maintenant il faut s'occuper de tout
et
et ne pas se laisser trop volés par par
les piégeant ou par des amis souvent
alors marianne on va parler de votre vie
[Applaudissements]
alors notre vrai nom c'est marianne
poor's elle vous êtes né en allemagne à
nuremberg
votre père était médecin pendant la
guerre votre père a été enrôlés dans la
wehrmacht en tant que citoyen allemand
et il a été pendant un temps le
chauffeur d'hitler absolument c'est ça
il aimait faire ça pendant un moment
mais après ils n'étaient plus parce que
c'était trop difficile pour lui il est
devenu aussi un peu vieux
alors ils s'arrêtaient et ensuite il a
été dans l'armée d'occupation en france
il a été à bordeaux il a été à paris et
puis il a été envoyé sur le front russe
absolument il été fait prisonnier alors
quand vous aviez cinq ans vous avez
insisté à des grands rassemblements
nazis qui aviez lieu à nuremberg et à
une personne dans votre famille qui
voulait pas y aller c'était votre
grand-père effet 14,8 absolue est
pacifiste et les disait toujours vous
allez voir où ce monsieur hitler va vous
amener pas grand chose vous allez voir
aimé mon père et mon oncle et il sait
mais là il mon grand-père était contre
quand les bombes alliées commence à
menacer nuremberg vous vous réfugier
dans un château bavarois et un jour vous
promener dans le château et vous trouvez
tassé à 6 dans une soupente secrète vous
découvrez donc deux familles de voisins
juifs cachés par vos grands parents
oui pendant qu'on perd surtout est ma
grand mère de toute manière elle fait
c'est toujours ce que mon grand père me
disait de faire c'était les femmes à
l'époque obéissons à l'hommage aux
grands parents étaient des juste
derrière grand père l'a payé parce qu'il
était arrêté par la gestapo emmené dans
un camp est finalement libéré par les
autres et par les américains
et quotidien venez avec le temps mon
grand père était 2e sur l'entente de
village c'est démontrer comment comme un
héros alors oui comme ils étaient ils
étaient 1
il a tout fait tout à fait alors après
la guerre votre mère meurt à l'époque où
vous avez neuf ans et le pire c'est que
votre père se remarie avec une polonaise
une dénommée verra et vous la détestez
à voir absolument elle me détester et
bien sûr un mot si elle me rendis la vie
tellement impossible c'est s était le
cauchemar quoi s était une femme jalouse
de ma mère parce que il voyait dans moi
ma mère alors elle me rendait la vie
impossible matin au soir et comme mon
père rentré il lui disait tout ce que
j'ai fait mal toute la journée pour
qu'il y ait ce mais selon moi aussi et
je devais toujours mangé dans la cuisine
quittait la salle à manger la table ma
dans la cuisine moi je la bats tu n'as
pas du mérite être avec moi c'était
comme ça tout le long je pleure et plus
que j'ai mangé et là où ça a été
terrible c'est quand est arrivé une demi
soeur c'est à dire que votre père et
verra ans maintenant et là elle était de
toute évidence la préférée et vous étiez
encore plus rejeter marianne beaucoup
plus et je pouvais pas jouer avec elle
on m'a pas laissé jouer mais avec m
c'est comme j'avais la paix ce mois un
alors en soir vous entendez dans la
chambre d'à côté votre belle-mère donc 7
verra
gémir et vous dit ça y est il a tu es en
fait pas du tout elle arrive dans le
matin pimpante mais qu'est ce que je
vais faire l'amour et willow à 14 ans
marianne vous êtes renvoyé du pensionnat
à 16 ans vous trouvez votre premier job
dans un institut de beauté à 17 ans vous
êtes mannequin et c'est vrai que dans
l'allemagne calviniste des années 50
fait des ravages avec votre fameuse robe
bleue sa tablette et j'ai beaucoup
mettre cette robe le décolleté voilà
c'était sexy je m'étais autre chose que
les autres je voulais différents et
j'étais différente avec une robe qui
découvrait largement la moitié de votre
poitrine je crois qu'on peut le dire
aujourd'hui il ya prescription mariale
le tout sur de gigantesques talons
aiguilles noires vielles une dégaine on
pourrait dire qu'ils étaient pas banal
dans le nuremberg de l'après guerre
totale à lui monsieur mais à 18 ans il
est toujours vierge
absolument c'est ce qu'à 19 ans - bin
oui j'ai pris du temps swissinfo changer
de chapeau si on embauche options pas de
mygales c'est quoi
ce n'est pas l'amour de dieu
si c'était des pattes de mygales abo
c'est doux c'est doux c'est d'où cette
traite de con c'est déjà ça qu'on va les
toucher
mais ça
macedo
[Applaudissements]
me ludot
je le dois
le petit whaou
voilà
la bise la mise en biseau
c'est son anniversaire aujourd'hui
birthday présent les atteintes aux biens
continue
ouais marianne on continue donc vous
êtes vierge jusqu'à l'âge de 19 ans mais
vous finissez par céder à un certain
gerhardt voilà mandanda mois de 19 ans
le premier oui et qu'est ce qu'il a fait
de spécial pour vous avoir celui là il
était un peu comme vous dans le champ
vous savez habran les yeux chaîne les
yeux un peu piétions un joli sourire
mettez la montre comme vous
m
voici les diètes experts c'est ce que je
veux
oui n'avait pas peur de la grippe vous
l'avez maintenant moi je fais des trucs
bien plus donc ce guérard était donc un
garçon très séduisant on peut le dire
après car c'est lui qui vous a eue
c'était votre premier garçon mais vous
le tromper aussitôt avec miguel grands
coiffeurs de la ville
celui qui avait la cadillac blanche pour
moi chez clis et là c'est chez voulait
pas mais
etc d'autres monsieur michael il était
très fort très sûr de lui car c'était un
homme très jeune vous n'avez pas
l'expérience lot est venu avec une
assurance de luffy et tout ça et j'ai
presse contre vous voyez j'ai pas voulu
vraiment je sais pas j'ai cédé pour lui
faire plaisir
enfin en tous les cas quand vous avouer
cette faute parce que c'est une foule
j'ai trompé pour toi ah oui c'est vrai
ça fait quoi oui ça l'est pas non il
fallait pas quand vous l'avouer à gerard
vous vire m'a longtemps je n'ai pas voué
à mon avis je n'aurais jamais dû le
faire parce que vous dites d'ailleurs
vous un conseil que vous donnez aux
femmes prennent vous pour vous laetitia
jamais jamais donc le problème le
problème si vous vous retrouvez enceinte
avortement votre père vous répudie
absolument vous ne l'avez jamais revu
votre père et quand il est mort en 2001
vous n'êtes même pas aller à
l'enterrement
non mais je les ai pas donné je suis
allé à monaco dans une église j'ai prié
pour lui a quand même et je ne lis pas
bien il a alors votre vie continue vous
vous continuez à rendre fou les hommes
de préférence des hommes riches quand
même hein et donc là vous allez vous
installer à genève marianne et vous
rencontrer le roi et la reine de
thaïlande à st moritz
voyez la sonacotra organismes victor
emmanuel de savoie et bizarrement ils
m'ont tant il monte en oui parce que
j'ai cassé en ski ma chambre et j'étais
à courchevel oui dans un hôtel qui
s'appelle carolina aux quelque chose
comme ça et lui il y avait beaucoup
d'escalier et comme j'avais des pesquies
j'étais comme ça et quelqu'un venait par
derrière et me mettais comme ça le mans
la taille et
se lever comme ça et changer quand
c'était lui est-ce que vous avez une
aventure avec yves montand
je dois répondre à ça bon écoute on a
compris et avec gilbert bécaud qu'est-ce
qui va voler laurent c'est bien mais ça
qu'elle danse gibet gilbert bécaud et
donc aussi monsieur avis monsieur avis à
quoi les locations de voitures les
voitures vous destinez l'avion là mais
attention parce que le mec qui à la
cible ou les voitures c'est pas monsieur
avis à vous attaquer un vous devenez
mariale une aventurière au sens saint
moritz du terme mais aussi une
aventurière au sens afrique du terme
puisque vous êtes amoureuse à l'époque
d'un étudiant péruvien qui s'appelle
pedro et vous le suivi en afrique pour
aller chercher des diamants bruts 1
çà et là c'était vraiment un moment de
ma vie que j'aimerais pas manquer ça
c'était quelque chose vraiment unique au
monde pour une femme vivent en afrique
fait les diamants bruts
allez dans les mines acheté la
marchandise le roman d'envoyer à anvers
et tout ça et et tous les choses qui se
présentait en afrique
on s'est beaucoup de cols sur l'afrique
ya trop de golf alors exactement les
scorpions la malaria
car il y a des biens et a du mal et a
toujours les deux romanesque
malheureusement pedro est abattu
comme un chien fou lire absolument un
coup de fusil ah oui c'est souvent le
cas quand on est abattus ou alors un
coup de fatigue et vous jetez votre
dévolu marianne sur l'un des hommes les
plus riches de jeûneurs monsieur rasa
mais encore
et donc là vous avez pris le thé avec
les beatles c'est vrai oui absolument ce
soir à bonal richmond à l'époque oui et
alors
mais a toujours un monte-carlo oui mais
pas ringo
comme toujours avec sa femme elle est
très jolie par balle à barbara bach wii
est très très belle femme très gentille
fond le gymnastique avec moi dans le
même temps la même salle il aurait mieux
fait de mourir comme john lennon alors
et vous rencontrez vous rencontrez aussi
bernard tapie absolument
si votre ami natacha c'est ça qui vous
présente bernard tapie à paris oui et
pourquoi vous voyez bernard tapie et ben
joie
elle m'a dit voilà on va déjeuner bien
monsieur chez maxim et il s'appelle
bernard tapie il y avait une énergie et
débordant oui toi je ne sais pas
maintenant je n'ai pas revu
nous voilà enfin bon finalement vous
vous séparez du riche genevois vous
partez au mexique seulement une
aventurière dans la danse très
romanesque à trier écrire un livre
vous allez au mexique alors vous êtes
dans un tournoi de backgammon j'avais
beaucoup le backgammon ça et vous
rencontrer le colonel parents
brandstetter sur les moments ex mari il
vous dit au début qu'il est célibataire
c'est ça oui mais j'ai compris tout de
suite après qu'ils aient été mariés ils
étaient effectivement marié depuis 30
ans déjà
mais est il avait une femme qui était
mentalement malade mais ne rentrait
toujours dans les cliniques pour se
soigner elle est à nouveau bien pendant
un petit moment
et vous elle rechute est donc là vous
vous installer à acapulco qui est la
capitale de la jet set internationale de
l'époque
vous finissez par épouser le bar en
brawn stetter et vous vivez ou pas
lebron stetter acapulco alors il ya des
gens comme nixon qui viennent
johnson
keith singer bon voilà c'est très ses
amis à mon ex mari voilà parce qu'il ya
quand même oui si elle espère tout ça et
et nancy ville et aussi sa femme la mère
de nancy et on faisait des petits dîners
en eau des petits dînette de que tu dis
à personne ayant des choses très simples
un jour à monaco vous tombez
effectivement sur james crosby est là
alors en scène tournoi de pâques à
manger actuellement à malines
vous êtes aussi un petit peu amoureuse
de lui mais vous lui montrez pas et vous
le faites attendre certains croient vous
êtes une joke témoin je n'aurais pas
aimé tomber sur vous j'espère que ça va
bien se passer entre nous ou le fait non
mais vous faites attendre c'est terrible
que le pauvre pour 20 minutes auparavant
des mois entiers des mois entiers si
l'homme qui se trouve tellement seule
abandonnée
ouais vous pouvez aller en avance
peut-être plus vite
mais si vous voyez à l'homme qui est
entouré pas toutes les femmes du monde
parce qu'on a joué few 9e ouais alors
vous allez vous précipiter son ennui
banon mais non voilà tu as vu larusso
stratégie alors là c'est une stratège
terrible alors finalement et vous emmène
aux bahamas et vous découvrez qu'il
dirige une société qui s'appelle 800
internacional qui emploie 6000 personnes
mais pour votre mari le baron
brandstetter il dit james crosby c'est
un match au zoo quand même non c'est ça
pour lui
oui mais c'était en réemployant vrai
mais en fait c'est
ces bolides parce qu'il n'était même pas
mafieuse il était contre la mafia
karine organisation qui s'appelait intel
y avait une quarantaine d'hommes des
sprites qu'il a protesté de la mafia et
les hawks nice crâne
les clips une aide aux organisations
parallèles c'est ça oui alors c'était
même pas très drôle parce que vous les
gars je suis magie juive ou sale
marianne vous les rencontrez des
commissaires des conseils nous font pas
peur vous c'est le moins qu'on puisse en
dire oui hiller après vous vivez maria
dans un luxe et freiner une vie de rêve
et la james crosby tombe malade
emphysème
voilà c'est ça malheureusement et là les
assedic sa bobine il c'est très
difficile de mourir pendant quelques
années sa vie de ne pas avoir l'air de
ne pas pouvoir respirer
chaque souffle chaque fois vous faites
comme race est un effort c'est c'est une
immense comme ça d'abord y met et
l'oxygène dans le nez après on lui ouvre
et ici on le mettez la dans j'ai caché
dans ses chemises cravates tutoyer
jusque sur les tapis en bas c'est
épouvantable de voir ça à quelqu'un que
vous aimez mourir comme ça mais qui
s'est passé a ajouté je ne suis jamais
remise
je m'étais très courageux je tiens à
dire parce que les parents de jean
claude bille vous ont accepté vous en
adopter à ce moment là la famille
passait
non mais c'est vrai que vous avez été
extrêmement courageux s'est occupé de
lui jusqu'à la fin absolument j'ai tout
fait pour lui je les amenais ans je vis
aux médecins de tout ce que je pouvais
faire pour lui mais c'était trop tard il
se met trop avant ah bon avant combien
il a fumé pouvoir et qu'un paquet se
vend au téléphone sans sa récente soirée
une après l'autre chain se moquait bien
alors donc john crosbie meurt à
l'enterrement il est cette maîtresse
quand même un set ça pas mal d'épreuves
fumer quand même
la baronne
édité chez flammarion
messieurs
mais alors marianne vous dit pas 99 au
sujet du sexe les hommes avec les femmes
les hommes avec les hommes les femmes
avec les femmes par deux ou en solitaire
pas de problème si chacun est consentant
donc vous méritez une interview alerte
aux roses
[Applaudissements]
alors marianne préférez vous draguez
vous faire draguer le faire draguer vous
préféré embrasser ou vous faire
embrasser vous préférez caresser ou vous
faire caresser les cours ont préféré
larguer vous faire l'arrêt largué quel
est pour vous l'endroit idéal pour faire
l'amour dans une voiture
oui
cependant malgré ces bons fait ma mini
dans la bête
en effet c'est qu'on sent belge et
mariana dans quel endroit
etes-vous incapable de faire l'amour
dans un train ah oui même en première
j'ai essayé ça n'a pas marché on mange
pas pourtant dans le train de tomber
tout un abord vous avez besoin d'aimer
pour faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour
pour aimer et le préfet mais tapotage
vous préféreriez un homme qui baisent
très très bien mais qui est infidèle ou
un homme qui baisent très très mal mais
qui est fidèle
le premier a oui elle pense encore à son
mari vous préféreriez qui vous quitte
pour un homme pour une femme pendant un
an vous préféreriez qu'ils couchent avec
vous en pensant à une autre ou avec une
autre en pensant à vous
[Musique]
coucher avec moi enseignants même si
penser à une autre
oui un peu pour lui s'il pense à
dites-moi est-ce que faire l'amour par
téléphone s'est trompé non je crois pas
vous connaissez la question michel
rocard oui oui évidemment évidemment
même si c'est une petite [ __ ]
je veux pas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus